I have a million questions for you guys
but I like starting off with like a
curve
um for all three of you if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why and don't include
this project because obviously people
are going to watch we
I wish people could watch my plays but
that's impossible I wish I wish but only
because you have such a long time just
sort of craft it you get in the groove
and then once you're in that Groove the
plate closes so I wish that every people
could see like the play the day before
it closes that's like my uh that's on my
wish list but alas can live like theater
I feel blessed
you guys gonna come I I'll look I'll fly
out for it I have to it's up till April
oh even
I was gonna say where was my invite I
got
Stephen you're I have a ticket at the
will call every single day for you you
never thought for sure that's definitely
gonna work if I had a project that I
wish people would watch that wasn't this
I would say little voice that's my my
favorite one it was like it was music it
was hard it was dogs it was it was you
know so lovely and like a little it's
like the most the most the purest thing
I ever did in my career in film and
television I would say like some you
know the music I do with my brother I
think like we just put out a new song
I'd say some of that or I did a movie
called Palo Alto when I was like 17 and
it changed my life you know in a lot of
ways and I I'm really proud of that
movie and it just means a lot to me
jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys uh this is one of those Series
where you're trying to figure out
everything as each episode is going on
so I'm curious how much were you told
about regis's ultimate Arc and how
things were gonna go when you first
signed on and how much were you sort of
finding out script by script it was
scrim by Script but we got like this
incredible pilot script where you get
the entire tone is set up and then
there's this huge twist at the end where
I screamed when I read it and so I was
like I have to be a part of this I
didn't chased it
um and uh and the rest of the the rest
of the scripts were like Christmas
presents you just get in the email and
be like oh my God I can't believe I get
to do this this seat yeah sure I think
Tony uh he's his mind is like
amazed I I don't think I'd want to go in
but I I like where it's going Patty was
uh sort of the light in the first few
episodes so when I signed on it only
read the pilot or I'd only auditioned
with the material in the pilot so um so
I had a long conversation with him and
he didn't really know where he was
taking Patty like how things would
essentially play out but he did know
that he wanted to take her from A to Z
as far as like she starts off as one
thing and is her life completely
unravels by the end and um and I
remember once he floated the idea of
decapitating me violently that didn't
that didn't work or it didn't come to
pass but I was kind of looking forward
to that um
so I think he really did find it as as
it as it went and and that's part of why
it feels so I think strange and
immediate it feels on Twitter it wasn't
like based on some overall outline he
was really gone with this gut yeah yeah
I I feel like when I was presented with
the material and to audition with it I
knew uh Tony would tell me that Elaine
would
have to really struggle with her moral
compass and be pretty influenced by path
off but it was pretty elusive I I didn't
really know which direction she was
going to take
um and what choices she would make and
how she would do it and it was on the
Fly and I feel like that's what it would
have actually been like for Elaine so it
was it was really fun and a good
challenge I normally don't ask this
question but every I have not watched
Kristoff work on set but I've
interviewed him a few times and he is an
interesting person he is Kristoff and
I'm just curious what exactly is it like
working with Kristoff on set
um and I'm curious because the way he is
in in real life is and after the term is
interesting he's so unique he's so
uniquely himself and and I've
gotten so lucky getting to work with a
lot of great older actors and he's I
think the best experience I've had I I
think he really is one of the reasons
that he's making such a great villain is
that he actually has in his own strange
unique way a real warmth and a magnetism
that you're just drawn to and and uh and
yeah it's like a dream I would pinch
myself after doing that scene in a
Hummer with him you know all day I mean
like I cannot believe that I get to be
you know in this you know daily season I
think he's absolutely brilliant and it's
so kind it's so great to work with an
actor Your Heroes or don't meet people
that you look up to and this is just
um a real treat to be able to work with
somebody who is so authentically
themselves and through that authenticity
there's kindness and creativity and
honesty and Brilliance and a genuine
um genuine generosity to open opened his
heart to us as actors and I I felt it
um
all the time when we work together uh
and it was such a gift he's like an
onion you're just constantly peeling at
the lake because when you first meet him
you think oh what am I what an unusual
person because he is very still but he's
also very curious and he wants to know
about the minutia of your life the
that you think is the least interesting
about you he wants to know and and and I
think that's probably what makes him
such a great actor is that he really
wants to get in and and see how people
work and what they're going to bring to
the table but as far as a scene partner
it's you know like everybody was saying
it's it's just like having playing on
like a championship team with a star
player he just like
he's gonna he's gonna
serve you the ball every time and it's
going to be perfect and all you have to
do is just keep your eye on it and
that's it maybe it's like uh I don't
know LeBron James I would never say that
because that's what you said about him
okay
Amy's like coming she's like the
interview Thief you say you say
something that's good and she's like she
snaps up and then says it in a more
eloquent way I am very curious about how
actors prepare for big moments so for
all three of you hypothetically you have
a huge scene on a Tuesday something
that's going to be emotional or a really
dramatic you know it's gonna require a
lot out of you how early on are you
actually preparing for that moment
um is it like when you first get ready
to start shooting are you really going
into like hardcore mode the weekend
before can you sort of for each of you
can you sort of take me through how you
like to prepare for a big moment I
always think that it's either like you
do it on the day or you or you or you
spend a good amount of time like having
done plays you know you don't have the
benefit of the freshness that comes with
like saying something for the first time
you have to really find it and and it
also become it becomes kind of like a
muscle
um so I find for me it's like if I don't
have the time I'm doing an audition or
something I won't rehearse it too much
but if I if I have some time with it I
really have to that's more fun for me
anyways to dig in and find through my
imagination like find what it must feel
like for this character
um and something that I learned from Nat
too like I was doing a play at the same
time I was doing the consultant and he
sent me like this playlist or a few
songs and I and I used that still like
it to really get my head in and I and I
hadn't up to that point use music that's
a way but for this or for your play both
you're both yeah I think that the
preparation process is is pretty
um different for for each character and
I I would say for this
um
definitely having these scenarios in the
back of your mind and then
um
to have a bound to being prepared but
also like as Amy said having that sense
of freshness
um I think and also being open and able
to be flexible and collaborative with
the people around you I think that's
super important
um and just present
um I think that was a big part of the
process at least for me on this
particular job I like to keep some set
through music or through uh relaxation
or through I like to some semblance of
the mood of the scene in in me and in my
body and then at the end of the day I
like to just let it go but but I usually
try to it's like uh you know sometimes
if you let sometimes if you let it go at
lunch or something then then it's a big
there's a bigger Hill to climb to get
back up you know
um so as soon as I try to I'll I'll try
to stay
stay in that zone for for the the time
being it's it's a it's actually ends up
being less energy for me than than the
people the up and down it's so
fascinating how there's just no right
answer and if you know everyone I speak
to is a different process but anyway
congrats on the series I hope it's a
huge hit for you guys thank you for
giving me your time thank you so much
Stevie